alfredier catom and patrice eduard
nysona listened quietly when the long
list of charges was read out
murder rape recruitment of child
soldiers they both denied
any involvement
mr president i repeat i don't recognize
myself in the accusations against me
i am not guilty
but prosecutors say they have
overwhelming evidence that jaka tom and
naisona have led the anti-balaka
movement in a campaign meant to remove
the muslim population from the country
jaeka thomas known as commander rambo
and aisona a right-hand man of former
president francois bouzize
as the organizer as the evidence will
show and gessona's participation in this
strategy was
integral and he contributed to it fully
aware that the group
he was helping to structure arm
finance instruct and organize
known by september 2013 as the
anti-balaka
would inevitably target the muslim
civilian population in western car
the violence started in 2013 after
muslim rebels from the selekar group
forced former president bautista out of
power
in revenge antibalaga groups killed
thousands of muslims and forced more
than one million from their homes
more than 1400 victims are expected to
take part in this trial
a trial that will be closely watched in
central african republic
the message from the icc is clear no
more impunity for those
involved in these crimes but the
question is how this message will be
received by those still involved in the
fighting
rebel groups have again taken control
over parts of central african republic
after the presidential election last
december
the government has accused boutis of
being behind the violence and is now
being investigated for rebellion
what we are also looking for is how the
other
rebel leaders the militia leaders will
react to this prosecution
will there be scare of icc
and therefore improve the behavior limit
the
atrocities that they are committing
against the population
or conversely will there decide that
the only way for them to remain safe is
to continue their criminal activity
the defense is yet to make their opening
statements a leader
of the selecam militia is also in
custody of the icc
showing that the court is serious in
holding both sides accountable
step fasten al jazeera the hake